firstly we would like to find greater
Manchester police the prosecution
Council and victim support for the
tallest work and help
we would also like to thank the doctors
and nurses who worked endlessly trying
to save Luke on the night of his death
Luke was our beautiful youngest son and
also a wonderful little brother
healed without doubt the glue in our
family that we can never replace and
we're all very proud of him and how he
conducted his life
all our lives now feel empty without
Luke
Luke was an extremely considerate loving
and generous
and we all enjoyed spending time lots of
time with him
Luke had a truly infectious love of life
with many Ambitions and hopes which
unfortunately he did not get to fulfill
he did not get to fulfill these hopes
and Ambitions because his life was
snatched away from him by a coward using
a knife
Shiloh pottinger
who has shown no remorse
Luke was killed by eight knife wounds to
the body in a random attack over
following a flip and skateboard comment
how many more parents and families and
friends have to go through the pain and
the heartache that night crime brings
the sentence in issue today does not
reflect the magnitude of the crime or
the loss of Luke's life
as we have seen from Luke's death and
only and others only this week
night crime is becoming more and more of
a common occurrence
as a society we need to find a way to
control and and control the access to
the knives and to push for changes to
the law and especially the sentencing
around knife crime
thank you very much